[Musique]
bon les gars vous avez pas joué vous
avez peur c'est ça
dans une pipe quand on arrive à
lasbordes oppresse jus d'orange
c'est ça qu'il fallait que je partage ce
soir c'était d'un esprit unique avec une
métaphore à la puissance inouïe c'était
il ya à peu près dix ans avec mon équipe
du hc trois chaînes
on était sur une patinoire vaudoise on
sortait d'un premier tiers avec un
engagement proche du zéro et ça à notre
entraîneur ça lui a pas plu je pense je
devais être dans les premiers visés moi
je t'ai le mec qui allait acheter le
meilleur équipement nouvelles baskets
nouveau choc mais qui sortait pas courir
quoi du coup allait mettre la charge
c'était impossible
la dessert il passait ou tout tout tout
tout voici mon grand vas-y mon grand mon
grand père exécuté un sénateur sur la
glace enfin bref je t'ai pas le type
engagé quoi toujours est il que ce jour
là j'ai peut-être pas pris conscience du
potentiel énorme que cette phrase elle
avait j'ai sûrement pris plutôt d'un
côté uniquement sportifs et encore que
je me rappelle même pas du résultat
final
toujours est il qu'au fil de ma vie et
grâce à des moments clés je peux lui
donner petit à petit un contenu en 2015
j'ai été catapulté à bogota à
l'université nationale de colombie pour
y réaliser mon échange académique amigos
a mis à l'essai mme bitat mossaka
participants nano est la classe
éducation populaire
les amis c'était un peu il était un peu
timbré quoi ils m'ont ils m'ont invité à
les accompagner un dimanche matin alors
que moi à l'époque c'était plutôt le
jour j'essaie d'éviter le regard de ma
mère a encore avec les yeux tout vitreux
allait donner
un cours d'éducation populaire dans un
des quartiers les plus défavorisés de la
ville
quelle leçon de vie incroyable
ces jeunes il allait donner des cours
dans ces quartiers pauvres alors que eux
mêmes
bon nombre de semestre ils devaient les
repoussée parce qu'ils n'avaient même
pas la capacité de payer leurs frais de
scolarité
enfin bref ça m'a donné envie de
m'engager tout ça et du coup lorsque
j'ai dû rentrer en suisse pour réaliser
mon service civil j'ai choisi de partir
au rwanda en service à l'étranger dans
les premiers jours je suis en train de
décrire un message sur mon téléphone à
ma copine et on partait à destination de
russie zykë dans le sud kivu à la
frontière avec la rdc donner une
formation à à une centaine de femmes
victimes de violence de violences faites
aux genres et là tout d'un coup je
ramasse mon téléphone je me relève
je nettoie les lunettes on venait de
prendre un camion bien articulé d'une
quarantaine de tonnes en face de nous
c'était 10 11 heures du soir dans la
fiole la forêt de new wave donc noir on
voyait rien un blessé c'était le
chauffeur sur le coup
mes collègues tétanisé jordi les gars
c'est vous qui devez y aller c'est vous
qui parlez kinyarwanda quoi finalement
personne n'ya été c'est moi qui
l'accompagné enfin bref le plus
important dans l'histoire est la leçon
que j'ai pu recevoir c'est que le
lendemain matin
si on s'était couché à 3 heures du matin
et qu'on avait acheté de 10 cm à mort on
était ensemble en tant qu'équipe a
dispensé notre formation comme s'ils
donnaient rien 2 comme si de rien
n'était parce que finalement on était là
pour servir à ces femmes
ces deux expériences elles m'ont
finalement mené à réfléchir et me dire
tu as vu tous les engagements que tu
avais sous ses yeux
toi aussi tu peux le faire tu peux le
faire si tu presses le jus d'orange
c'est à dire que tu sors de ta zone de
confort tu prends un risque
du coup il ya quatre jours je suis
revenu de 2 passes au passo marinho
pastorino colombie j'ai décidé d'ouvrir
une auberge de jeunesse pour développer
une économie formelle pour créer des
jobs et valoriser une région à fort
potentiel touristique
mais qui et qui pêchent encore dans
l'offre
clairement quand il prend ce genre
d'initiative où tu presses jus d'orange
s'est exposé à des risques tu te
retrouves dans les situations
désagréables
tu as des emmerdes pour dire sans quoi
il ya deux mois
j'avais cette opportunité en or de
postuler pour être ici devant vous ce
soir un rêve et ça donne ça demande du
temps je devais préparer une vidéo et en
même temps j'avais été sélectionné après
un mois de travail dans mon département
pour partir en mission commerciale à
médine représenter mon département et le
promouvoir dans tout le pays sauf que
une fois de plus l'administration
colombienne a plus d'un tour dans son
sac
on avait refusé mon permis de séjour à
bogota parmi ces jours entre soit dit en
passant qui me permette d'exercer ma
profession et on avait envoyé en
equateur du coup j'ai dû réaliser une
cinquantaine soixantaine de cette vidéo
pourrait trotter l'x pendant que faisait
cette heure d'allers-retours trois jours
consécutivement à la frontière
équatorienne au consulat colombien enfin
bref c'est le genre de moment où tu es
peau mais quoi qu'il arrive pas du coup
c'est un peu comme
c'est un candidat qui sèche donc qui
veut gagner des millions face à jean
pierre foucault
il appelle un ami voilà tu appelles la
philosophie presse orange parce que tu
es cuit
enfin bref je sens que j'ai en débutant
je suis au début mon processus de
presser le jus d'orange
j'ai la chance depuis maintenant 6 mois
avec une collègue de travail
je vais vous faire le cv de manière
relativement courte et succincte
déplacés du conflit armé par les
nécessités libération nationale en 2003
on les a laissés 15 minutes pour prendre
ses cliques et ses claques et partir
chez elle elle a trois enfants plage de
16 ans ella diehl arrêté l'école à l'âge
de 11 ans au moment où je parle
elle gère tout seul l'auberge que j'ai
monté ma conclusion c'est quoi on a tous
notre orange d'or cette personne qui
nous guide et qui nous d'y aller de plus
c'est ça qui voulaient nous dire notre
entraîneur il ya dix quinze ans c'était
pas simplement changer le cours du match
c'était non les gars c'est pas parce que
tu es petit c'est pas parce que tu es
frêle c'est pas parce que tu es moyens
techniquement que tu vas pas récupéré le
contrôle du jeu si tu melkor boom tu
mets ta charge c'est toi le maître du
jeu si ma collègue elle a su prendre son
destin en main
elle y arrive malgré des conditions de
départ proche du zéro on peut tous y
arriver
tous les défis sont surmontables
tous les projets sont réalisables
aucun rêve est inaccessible
la seule et unique condition c'est qu'il
faut presser le jus d'orange
alors que genève
qu'est ce qu'on va faire les jours qui
viennent c'était pas ma sai t pas mal
c'était pas mal je m'attendais à pire
toujours est il que j'ai pas dit la
famille et les amis qu'est ce qu'on va
faire les jours qui viennent je veux
tout genève genève
qu'est ce qu'on va faire les jours qui
viennent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]